[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good evening, and welcome to
the College of Science lecture
series.
You thought that it couldn't
get any better after Chris
Impey gave his
lecture last Tuesday,
but you're in for a treat today.
[CHEERING]
I want to thank the
underwriters of this lecture
series, the reason why you don't
have to pay $5 at the entrance.
It is my pleasure today to
introduce Michael Turner,
the speaker for today.
[LAUGHTER]
That's right.
Michael Turner is a theoretical
astrophysics and director
of the Kavli Institute
for Cosmological Physics
at the University of Chicago.
As an aside, I'd
like to remind you
that this year, one of the
prize winners for the Kavli
Prize, which is a
sort of a Nobel Prize,
was our own Roger Angel from
the astronomy department.
But let's continue here.
[APPLAUSE]
Michael received his
Bachelor of Science
from Caltech, his masters of
science and PhD from Stanford.
He has helped pioneer the
interdisciplinary field
of particle astrophysics
and cosmology.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
His scholarly
contributions include
predicting cosmic acceleration
and coining the term dark
energy, showing how quantum
fluctuations evolved
into the seat
perturbations for galaxies
during cosmic inflation,
and several key ideas that
led to the cold dark matter
theory of structure formation.
His honors include the
Warner Prize of the American
Astronomical Society,
the Lilienfeld Prize
of the American
Physical Society,
the Klopsteg Award for
the American Association
of Physic teachers, the
Heineman prize of the American
Astronomical Society and the
American Institute of Physics,
and the 2011 Darwin Lecture of
the Royal Astronomical Society.
He is currently chairman
of the board of the Aspen
Center for Physics and a
member of the governing
board of the National
Academy of Sciences.
In 2013, Dr. Turner will serve
as a president of the American
Physical Society.
How he ever made time
to be with us tonight
is one of the true great
mysteries of the universe.
[LAUGHTER]
Please welcome our special guest
tonight, Dr. Michael Turner.
Thank you very much
[APPLAUSE]
It's a great pleasure
to be here tonight--
OK, there's my version--
--To talk about these big
mysteries of cosmology.
And I understand that I was
given homework assignments
by both Chris Impey
and by Father Guy.
Now, I'm not so
worried about Chris,
because I think I can
hold my own with him.
But when you've got
a Jesuit priest who's
closely associated
with the Vatican,
you have to be careful.
So I'm hoping that--
I mean, I'm not
going to proceed
unless you all agree
to tell Father Guy that I
answered all the questions
that I was supposed to.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So let's see.
Oh, there's the arrow.
So I think the
reason that we have
so many people here is that
you all appreciate that we are
in a revolutionary period of
discovery about the universe
and our place in it.
It's extraordinarily exciting.
And I like to think
that it's powered
by powerful instruments.
Now, you in Arizona
know a lot about making
instruments and mirrors.
And I had the pleasure
of being there
when Roger Angel
received the Kavli Prize.
By bold ideas.
So I'm going to talk about
instruments, bold ideas.
And what makes it most
exciting for scientists
are really big mysteries.
Because science is
more fun when you're
trying to solve a puzzle.
And so I'm going to be talking
about all three of these things
tonight.
The powerful instruments, the
bold ideas, and the mysteries.
Now, I'm just going to
back up a little bit.
Well, I'm not going to
ask if everybody was here
for the other two
lectures, or if you
remember everything
that was said,
but I'll back up a little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
Just to remind you of
what you've heard before,
to put everything in context.
The universe is very,
very big, and it's often
beyond the grasp of our
minds and our instruments.
And so most of modern
cosmology doesn't even
date back 100 years.
And so you heard about Hubble.
And Hubble was the
one who pointed out
that the universe doesn't have
just one galaxy, but billions
of galaxies by
resolving the stars
in the nebulae on the sky.
And he also discovered that
the universe is expanding.
And probably Chris
and Father Guy
neglected to tell you that
Hubble got all of his degrees
at the University of Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
And I am required
to tell you that.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'll show you
Hubble's data here.
Some people think
that Hubble is famous
because here was
a bunch of coffee
stains on a piece
of graph paper,
and he was able to draw a
straight line through it.
[LAUGHTER]
But Hubble was a
great scientist.
And Einstein played an
important role in this
because without Einstein's
Theory of Gravity,
we wouldn't have the proper
interpretation for what's
going on.
It's not that galaxies are
actually moving away from us,
it's that the
universe is expanding.
So Einstein taught us that time
warps and space is flexible.
And the best example
of space being flexible
is the expansion
of the universe.
And so the galaxies are
just moving away from us
due to the expansion
of the universe.
And so I have a little
simulation here to show you.
I got a bunch of
galaxies on a slide here,
and through the
miracle of PowerPoint,
I just blew up the space.
And so the galaxies
are then further apart,
and I did it again.
And then let's look
at what this looks
like from the point of
view of our galaxy, which
is at the center of the
universe, of course.
[LAUGHTER]
And so it looks to us
like other galaxies
are moving away from us.
And the ones that
are farthest from us,
cover more distance in a
certain amount of time, which
means they're moving faster.
So it explains Hubble's law.
And I'm sure both
Chris and Father
Guy explained that
actually, we are
at the center of the
universe, but everybody is
at the center of the universe.
So if we picked any other
galaxy, say that one,
and just looked at what it saw,
it sees exactly the same thing.
So this expansion of space,
everybody sees the universe.
Everybody sees all the other
galaxies moving away from it
and thinks that it's at
the center of the universe.
And actually, that's
a Harvard phenomenon,
but it really does
work in the universe.
[LAUGHTER]
And so this expansion
of space, the universe
is just scaling up.
And then the discovery of the
cosmic microwave background
by Penzias and Wilson
in 1964 told us-- well,
I should have said that the
implications of Hubble's
discovery was, in the beginning,
the universe was small,
and it got bigger and evolved.
And so there was a big bang.
Penzias and Wilson
discovered that there
are billions of
microwave photons filling
the universe for every atom
and that this is the heat
leftover from the Big Bang.
And that the Big Bang
was a hot Big Bang.
And that changes everything,
because in the beginning,
it was really hot.
And I'm going to use
a technical term here.
It was hotter than hell.
[LAUGHTER]
I think I'm allowed to do that
because Father Guy probably
said the same thing.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know, when
you heat something up,
you reduce it to
its basic elements.
And so that means that
in the beginning--
[LAUGHTER]
--The universe was
a primordial soup.
So this is 1964, Penzias
and Wilson, hot Big Bang.
And so what is
primordial soup made of?
And so in the 1970s,
we figured out
what the basic pieces, what the
basic building blocks of matter
are.
And those are called quarks.
And that was done
with experiments
at this linear accelerator
in Chicago, Illinois.
[LAUGHTER]
The two-mile long
Stanford Linear-- or I
guess it's in California.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, you know why Chicago
is called the Windy City,
don't you?
It has nothing to
do with weather.
[LAUGHTER]
So it was experiments done at
the Stanford Linear Accelerator
that showed the following,
that-- so everybody knows
about atoms.
And they have a nucleus made
of neutrons and protons.
And these experiments showed
that the neutrons and protons
were made of smaller
entities called quarks.
And so by knowing that and
combining that with the fact
that the universe was
hot in the beginning,
we can figure out what
that primordial soup was.
So I'm going to show
you a full-scale model
of the entire universe
that we can see today,
what it would have looked
like at the beginning.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is done to scale.
I didn't say it's
the entire universe.
It's everything
we can see, which
is 100-- I think Chris
Impey told you-- there's
100 billion galaxies all
fit in this soup can.
And they were reduced to
their core constituents.
OK.
So this is what we know.
We can now reconstruct the
history of the universe
from quark soup to us.
And this reconstruction took
about 13.7 billion years,
so I'm not just going
to step you through it.
I'll speed it up
just a little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
So when the universe was younger
than one 100,000th of a second,
it was this quark soup.
And as we follow it through,
it's expanding, it's cooling,
layer upon layer of
structure is building up.
And so when it was about one
100,000th of a second old,
it was cool enough for
neutrons and protons to form.
Now, I know all of you
took science classes,
and you all know
that protons are blue
and neutrons are green.
[LAUGHTER]
And as it cooled, it became
cool enough for the neutrons
and protons to come together and
make the nuclei of the lightest
elements in the
periodic table, and that
happened when the universe
was a few seconds old.
When the universe was
a few seconds old,
it was a nuclear reactor.
And that nuclear reactor
made a lot of helium.
It made a little
bit of deuterium.
It made some helium three, so
that's a light form of helium,
and it made a tiny
amount of lithium.
The rest of the elements
in the periodic table
were made in stars.
And I believe it's next week
that Phil Pinto is going
to tell you about how stars made
the rest of the periodic table.
Now, I know that intelligent
design is a hot issue.
[LAUGHTER]
And I want to use
you as a focus group
here and give you
my best argument
against intelligent design.
My best argument against
intelligent design
was the tiny amount of lithium
that was made in the Big Bang.
If it was really
intelligent design,
the creator would
have known that we
needed much more lithium to
deal with our mental health
problems.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Well, the focus group
likes that argument.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So we now have nuclei.
Universe is cooling
and expanding.
And when it's about
400,000 years old,
it's cool enough for the
nuclei to capture electrons.
And now we have atoms.
And once the atoms form-- this
is a very interesting time
that we'll come back
to-- once the atoms form,
the light in the universe,
the radiation in the universe,
travels long distances.
And so this is the farthest
point that we can see back to.
And I'll come back
to that again,
and I bet Chris
talked about that.
And then gravity took over.
Gravity is the master builder.
We'll talk more about that.
And stars, and galaxies, and
so on and so forth were made.
And so we can reconstruct
the history of the universe
from this early
time until today.
And along the way,
we have tests.
So this is not
just a nice story.
This is a story that's
supported by scientific fact.
So we predict how much
helium, deuterium, lithium,
and helium three
is made back there,
and ask if the most primitive
samples of universe-- that
is, samples of the universe that
haven't been through stars--
have that amount.
And so we can test this theory
all the way back to about 10
to the minus five seconds.
OK.
So let me talk about some of
the measurements that we make
with the instruments
that we have today
that explore this vast universe,
vast both in space and in time.
So the universe, the part
of the universe, we can see,
is about 13 billion
light years across,
and the universe is about
13 billion years old.
These are numbers that are very
hard to get your head around.
But we now have
instruments that can
take us all the way to the
edge of the visible universe
and back in time.
So let me show you some
of those instruments.
Now, this slide I probably
don't need to show you.
And probably, I'm in a little
bit of trouble for showing you,
because I think you all know
about big optical telescopes.
And unfortunately, I don't have
any Arizona telescopes here.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Well, actually,
let me talk about
these European
telescopes, because I
can tell another joke here so--
[LAUGHTER]
The Europeans have their
telescopes in Chile.
These are four 8.2
meter telescopes.
You need a special camera
to be able to photograph
all of these telescopes
when standing
on top of the mountain.
And they had a recent
distinguished visitor
who visited Paranal, is
their observatory in Chile.
I visited it.
It's a really spectacular place.
And this visitor
said, you know, this
is the way God would have
done it if he had the money.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is really--
well, in Chicago,
we use Thorstein
Veblen, who just called
this conspicuous consumption.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is the
Gemini telescope,
and-- oh, actually, these
are Roger Angel mirrors.
These are the Magellan
telescopes in Chile.
So these are Roger
Angel mirrors.
And then the two
biggest telescopes
in the world, the
Keck telescopes.
And of course, we have
telescopes in space.
We have our first space
telescope, the Hubble,
but we also have the Chandra.
Oh, let's see, Chandra was
at the University of Chicago.
Hubble was at the
University of Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we have the Fermi
Gamma Ray Observatory.
Oh, Fermi was at the
University of Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we have the Spitzer.
Well, Spitzer must have been
at the University of Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, he never taught there, but
he did go through O'Hare once.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I think all
of you are aware,
everybody here in
the audience probably
has a digital camera in
their pocket or their purse.
And these cameras that use
charged-coupled devices
are extraordinary
for two reasons.
Number one, the old photographic
plates that Hubble used only
collected about 1% of the light.
These CCD's collect
almost 100% of the light.
And you can digitize
the picture.
You can distort it.
You can make it look
like anything you want.
You can put it on the web.
Actually, you can do really
good scientific stuff with it.
And the cameras that we have
now, 100 megapixel are common,
and the biggest ones
are a billion pixels.
And this has changed
the way astronomy
is done for the better.
So I want to show you the
most famous picture in all
of astronomy, and I also
want to congratulate you
on your good taste.
So this is called the
Hubble Deep Field,
or the Hubble point and shoot.
How many people have seen this?
I should ask, how many
people haven't seen this?
So this image of the
universe cost you $2 billion.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was worth every penny.
It was a bargain.
So this answers the
age-old question,
how far can you
see on a clear day?
[LAUGHTER]
So this is as far
as you can see,
and the reason that you can't
see any farther than this
is you're looking
out so far in space
that you're looking
back to the time
when galaxies were being born.
And if you looked out
any farther in space,
there weren't galaxies to see.
So this truly answers, how far
can you see on a clear day.
Just let me wax poetic a
little more about this.
This is about 1/10
millionth of the sky.
A tiny, tiny little
bit of the sky.
It's such a small part of the
sky that there's only one star.
Or let's see, is there two?
Depends how you crop it.
There's one.
I think there's only one.
The rest of the images in this,
all these other little funny
looking images, are galaxies.
There are several
thousand galaxies here.
If you multiply
that by 10 million,
you get the 100 billion number.
100 billion galaxies
in the universe.
And you'll notice that some
of these galaxies look funny,
and it's not that you
bought a crummy telescope.
It's that you're looking back
to galaxies being formed,
and so they don't look
like galaxies today.
So this is what the Hubble did.
This is one of
the-- you know, I'm
going to ask you to look at this
kind of like a Monet painting.
So don't get scared
away by the graphs here.
We can now construct-- we
live in an evolving universe.
There weren't always stars, and
there won't always be stars.
And so what we've been
able to reconstruct
is the star formation
history of the universe.
So this is time.
And don't worry about
these funny numbers here.
So this is the Big Bang
back here, and this is now.
So time moves from-- so think of
this as an Old Testament Bible.
You have to read it
from right to left.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is the rate at
which stars were forming.
So start out really slow.
And stars were really forming
a lot when the universe was
a couple billion years old.
This is the time up here.
And today, there's
hardly any stars forming.
We're just about
done forming stars.
And so this is the
star formation history
of the universe.
And then the Hubble diagram.
So we all laugh
at Hubble's data,
but he was the one
who showed us that we
live in an evolving universe.
So this is the best Hubble
diagram that we have.
And so, this again,
is the velocity
of galaxies moving away from
us versus their distance.
And now it actually
looks like these points
lie on a straight line.
And let me show
you Hubble's data.
So all of Hubble's data would
fit in this tiny little part
of the graph.
[LAUGHTER]
And here is the data
that he would have added.
And you know, his
data wasn't so good,
and I won't tell you
what value he got.
The correct value is about 70.
The value Hubble got was 550.
So this expansion
rate of the universe
is extremely important,
because the expansion rate
of the universe tells us how
long back to the Big Bang,
among other things, and
how big the universe is.
This also tells
us that girls are
better astronomers than boys.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is why we tried to
keep them out of astronomy.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not stupid.
So the team that measured
the Hubble constant
was led by Wendy Freedman.
Now, let's talk about how far
you can see with microwaves.
And so this is the cosmic
microwave background,
and this was a very
important discovery in 1992.
NASA sent up a satellite
called, its friends
called it COBE, cosmic
background explorer,
to carefully measure the
radiation from the microwave
background.
And for the technical
buffs here, it
measured the spectrum of
the microwave background
and found it to be almost
a perfect black body
with a temperature
of 2.7255 5 kelvin.
But what I really wanted
to talk about here
is this is how the intensity
of the microwave background
varies across the sky.
So this is the
whole sky projected
on a piece of graph paper,
like when you went to school,
they projected the whole
Earth on an ellipse.
So that's the whole sky.
And this is one of
these color diagrams.
And so you might say, well,
this is really boring.
Well, it is boring because
the intensity of the microwave
background is essentially
the same in all directions.
If you look at it
very, very carefully,
it's slightly more intense
or hotter in one direction.
This is towards the
constellation Leo.
Yeah, I wish I could
stop that, but I
don't know how to stop that.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's cooler in
the other direction.
This is called the
giant dipole in the sky.
Two poles, one
here and one there.
And it tells us that with
respect to the cosmic rest
frame of the
universe, we're moving
at 620 kilometers per second.
And that's interesting.
But what was most
interesting, and what
resulted in the Nobel Prize
for Mather and Smoot was this.
So if you take away
the dipole, there
are tiny fluctuations
in the intensity,
about a part in a 100,000--
or if you want it in kelvin,
about 18 micro kelvin-- that
were discovered by COBE.
And I'm going to tell you
how important they are.
This is not the belt
of the universe.
So this is microwave
emission from our own galaxy.
So you want to ignore that.
That's not important.
But it's these spots here
that are very, very important,
that we're worth a Nobel Prize.
And so let me explain why
they were worth a-- oh.
First of all, testimonials.
So Stephen Hawking, when this
announcement was made in 1992,
said, "Greatest
discovery of all time."
Now, you know, the Brits are
not known for their reserve.
They're way over exuberant,
and this may only
be a slightly overstatement.
So a California boy was a
little more reserved in his--
"This was a very big discovery."
And the reason it was
a very big discovery
is that this was the
evidence for the lumpiness
in the distribution of
matter in the universe
that seeded all the
structure that we see today.
And by structure, I mean
galaxies, and clusters
of galaxies, and stars, and us.
So that's a really big deal.
So let me come back and blow up
part of that earlier diagram.
So here we are.
We look out in space.
We look back in time.
And let's see, so here are
some of those galaxies that
were seen by the
Hubble Space Telescope.
So we go back to
when the universe was
about a billion years old, and
then we can't see anything.
As I told you before, that
the so-called dark ages,
where nothing was lit up.
And the photons that come from
the greatest distance to us
come from this time
when the universe
went from being nuclei
and electrons-- we
call that ionized matter--
to be two atoms forming.
And why that works, for
the technical people here,
is ionized matter is
very opaque to radiation.
And in fact, Joaquin, did
we get that waiver thing
so that we could turn
the room into a plasma
and then people wouldn't
be able to see me?
[LAUGHTER]
We didn't get-- we
didn't get that.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
We can't do my demonstration.
[LAUGHTER]
And so these microwave
photons go all the way back
to this time before stars when
the universe was almost uniform
mush with small variations in
the density of the universe.
So some regions were about 0.01%
more dense and other regions
were less dense.
And then gravity took
the more dense regions
and pulled in more material.
And then their
gravity got stronger,
and then more material fell in.
And so during the
next 13 billion years
or so, galaxies and other
structures built up.
And this model of how
structure formed by gravity
is, I think, a University of
Chicago Economics Department
model.
So if you think about it,
where there was more matter,
those regions got
even more matter.
So the rich get richer.
[LAUGHTER]
And where there's
less matter, you know,
they lose their matter to
where there's more matter.
So the poor get poorer.
So this was a model
built by University
of Chicago economists.
[LAUGHTER]
But kidding aside, the
small variations that we're
seen in the COBE map-- so
these blue regions have
slightly more matter
and the red regions
have slightly less matter.
And so this is a region
that will eventually
have-- well, actually, a
structure bigger than a galaxy.
But this lumpiness is what
seeded all the structure
in the universe.
OK.
Well, this was so important that
a whole series of experiments
followed this up because
the COBE map-- coming back
to it here-- the reason that
the spots have this size
is that's all the resolution
that the COBE microwave
telescope had.
And it wasn't that the
scientists and the government
didn't do a good
job building this,
it's that that's
all the resolution
that they could afford.
And so a series of
experiments followed this up
because you're seeing the
universe at an extraordinarily
simple time.
And you know, science is
a fantastic adventure,
adventure with a purpose.
So the experiments
that followed this up,
one was a balloon
that circumnavigated
Antarctica called Boomerang.
Another one, this is the
Daisy experiment and Akbar
experiment, two experiments
at the South pole.
And this is an experiment in
the Atacama Desert in Chile.
And the ultimate experiment,
the best experiment
that we've done so
far at mapping out
this picture of the
infinite universe,
is done by an experiment
called The Microwave Anisotropy
Probe, that was the brainchild
of David Wilkinson, a Princeton
professor.
Well, he came up with this
idea when he was at Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was launched
here on 2001,
and produced the
prettiest map that we have
of the microwave background.
And it looks like this.
And this is how you can tell
if you're a cosmologist.
If you're a
cosmologist, this makes
your heart go pitter patter.
[LAUGHTER]
Most people think that this
map just looks like noise, just
like random noise.
And Stephen Hawking gets
very excited about this map,
because actually this
map is just random noise.
But look at that.
S H.
[LAUGHTER]
Stephen Hawking.
And so what we're seeing-- let
me just wax poetic about this.
What we are seeing
is the distribution
in the matter, this distribution
of matter in the universe, when
it was 380,000 years old.
Not 380,000 years ago, but
when it was 380,000 years old.
Before galaxies, before stars.
And you know, when you do one
of these false color maps,
it looks like, well, anybody
could have done this.
Look how big the contrast is.
We've got red, yellow, purple.
The variations in the
intensity of the microwave
background that were measured
by these experiments are 0.001%.
Does anybody know a good example
of what point a 0.001% is?
That's the difference between
the vote for Bush and Gore
in Florida in the year 2000.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you do some fancy
mathematics to this,
this is fancy
mathematics that you do.
And I don't want to spend
much time about doing this.
All of a sudden out of what
looks like noise, a signal
pops out.
And we call these
acoustic oscillations.
And the theory that I'm going to
tell you about predicted them.
And from measuring
how high this one is,
and how low that one
is with respect to it,
and so on and so forth,
we can learn things
about the universe.
Oh, and what I wanted to show
you is that for those of you
who knows multiple poles--
so this is basically
angular size on the sky.
This goes out to
about 2,000 here,
and it's been measured
to almost 3,000.
So you see lots and
lots of these bumps.
And it tells you about the
universe at a simpler time.
So let me summarize what
we know and then come
to these big mysteries.
So what do we know?
What do we have
evidence to support?
So we have evidence to support
the history from lumpy quark
soup, to nuclei, to
atoms, to galaxies,
and to even bigger structures
like clusters of galaxies.
I'll show you those in a second.
We know that the
universe is uncurved.
Let me talk about that.
I bet somebody-- I bet Chris or
Father Guy talked about that.
So Einstein told us that there
are three shapes for space.
And if we imagine a
two-dimensional universe rather
than our three-dimensional
universe,
we can picture these better.
So the universe can
curve back on itself.
That's a high-density universe,
one with lots of matter.
It causes space to
curve back on itself.
the universe can spring
out like a saddle.
Well, isn't this horse country?
You know about saddles.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's the
low-density universe.
Or it can just be uncurved.
And what we found is that we
are the uncurved universe.
So we're the flat universe.
And then I'm going to be
talking more about this.
The universe is
not only expanding,
but the expansion
is speeding up.
And the universe is made
of atoms, dark matter.
So I'll tell you more
about dark matter
in a second, and dark energy.
And I'll tell you a
lot more about that.
And we have evidence for
what caused the Big Bang,
a process called inflation.
And we can precisely
measure things,
from the microwave background
and other measurements,
that the amount of
matter in the universe
is 27 plus or minus
1.4% of-- we're
the uncurved universe that
has a certain density called
the critical density.
So that's 27% of the critical
density is in matter.
Atoms, the kind of stuff that
the chemists try to peddle you,
is 4.6%.
The difference between these
two numbers is very important,
and cosmologists didn't used
to be able to discriminate
between 27 and 4.6.
But now we can.
And then there's a
ton of dark energy.
And then we measure
the age and-- oh, I
see a mistake in this slide.
13.75 billion years,
plus or minus 0.11.
The mistake is that
this is a slide when
I gave the talk two weeks ago,
but I have to add in two weeks
to this.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, actually, we don't
quite measure things
that accurately yet.
But the term
precision cosmology,
if you went to your dictionary
and looked at oxymoron,
the first example was
precision cosmology.
[LAUGHTER]
But we're now able to measure
things very, very precisely.
And I want to talk
about making-- oh,
and I talked about the
expansion rate of the universe.
And I'm going to talk
a lot about the matter.
Oh, here we have a picture.
So here's the dark energy
that's most of the universe.
Here is the dark matter,
or what I call-- it's
the stuff that's not atoms.
We call that exotic dark matter.
And then here is the atoms.
And let's see, if you
want to feel very, very
small, the elements that
your bodies are made out of,
carbon, nitrogen, oxygen,
iron, and uranium-- I just
can't remember the Tom Lehrer
song about all the elements,
so those are the only
ones I remember-- account
for 0.02% of the universe.
And the rest is other stuff.
So what's wonderful
about this picture
here is that we actually
know about atoms,
and they're about
4% of the universe.
96-- we're patting ourselves
on the back for knowing a lot,
by being able to
make this pie chart
where we say that 4% we know
of and the other 96% we've
been able to name.
[LAUGHTER]
But I hope to convince you
by the end of this, that's
the time you want to get in a
scientific field, when there
are really, really big puzzles.
Because once it's all
known, it's not fun anymore.
OK.
We've already seen that slide.
So from this accounting
of the universe,
we got three big mysteries.
What's the dark
matter made out of?
And the dark matter, just
coming back to this slide here,
is so atoms can't account
for all the matter.
If you subtract that number
from that number, you get 23.
Well, actually maybe-- OK.
Call it 23, please.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we've got to explain
what is the dark matter.
And then this one
gets even worse.
So this is a technical term.
What the heck is
the dark energy?
[LAUGHTER]
And then, I have to tell you
about inflation and what it is
and what powered it.
OK.
So I'm on to the mysteries.
So dark matter.
So mostly we learn
about the universe
by looking through
telescopes made in Arizona.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And a lot of them are
located in Arizona.
For all I know, they're
all located in Arizona.
So how can we see stuff
that doesn't give off light?
And that's what I
want to talk about.
We can feel its gravity.
And the dark matter story
starts with Fritz Zwicky,
and he was a very,
very smart man.
Oh, I think I forgot
something in this slide.
So nowadays, he's
the kind of kid
who would get sent home
with a little tag on it,
does not play well with others.
[LAUGHTER]
And here in this picture,
Fritz is describing
what a spherical bastard is.
[LAUGHTER]
And a spherical
bastard is someone,
it's kind of like a dean.
[LAUGHTER]
Nothing personal.
You know, no matter what
direction you approach
this person, they're a bastard.
[LAUGHTER]
And OK.
Uh oh.
I better, I better--
I didn't mean a dean.
I meant a provost, of course.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So how did he
discover dark matter?
So he was the first
astronomer in the 1930s
to study clusters of galaxies.
And these clusters of
galaxies are giant collections
of galaxies where you see
a whole bunch of galaxies
on a small part of the sky.
This is the Hercules Cluster,
and every one of the smudges
is a galaxy.
And so these
clusters of galaxies
might have 2,000
or 3,000 galaxies.
And what Zwicky did was he
turned this beautiful picture
into this picture.
[LAUGHTER]
He measured how fast
these galaxies are moving.
So these galaxies are
not sitting still.
They're actually moving.
And he was able to measure
how fast they're moving.
And they're moving thousands
of kilometers per second.
And so he asked himself, well,
if they're moving so fast,
what keeps the cluster together?
And the answer is,
should be gravity.
Gravity is the universal glue.
It holds things together.
The planets in our solar system
move fast, not quite this fast,
and it's the gravity
of the sun that holds
the solar system together.
Except he found a
small, little problem.
If you add up all the
gravity of all the--
[LAUGHTER]
You know, this slide was perfect
when I put it in this machine.
[LAUGHTER]
It's this cheap
equipment you have here.
[LAUGHTER]
So if you add up all the
gravity of all the stars in all
the galaxies, it's not enough
to hold the cluster together.
It's off by a factor of 50.
And so Zwicky was
bold enough to say,
clusters must be held
together by the gravity
of unseen material.
Dark matter.
Now, there were
alternative hypotheses,
including that Fritz
Zwicky is crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
One of the
alternative hypotheses
is, there aren't
really clusters.
That was a chance passing
of galaxies in the night.
And it was-- you know,
cosmology was young.
Equipment wasn't good.
The idea didn't catch on.
But we now know that's true.
And in fact, we can
image the dark matter.
And let me show you another
wonderful Hubble image.
So this is a
cluster of galaxies.
So the orange galaxies
are in a cluster.
Oh, you can't see
the phone number.
That's right.
We blacked it out
because some people would
try to call it on their phone.
So this is a
cluster of galaxies.
And behind this
cluster of galaxies,
much farther away
in the universe,
are very faint galaxies
called faint blue galaxies.
We're really good
at naming things.
[LAUGHTER]
And the light from these
faint blue galaxies
that I'm pointing at has
to pass through the cluster
to get to us.
Now, one of the predictions
of Einstein's theory
is that gravity bends light.
And anything that bends
light we just call a lens.
So gravity acts like a lens.
And what it does is
produce multiple images.
So all of these
ring-like galaxies,
that's not a bunch of
galaxies that are twins.
That's multiple images
of the same galaxy.
And galaxy-- actually,
a gravitational lens
is not a great lens.
It distorts.
It shears.
It stretches the image of
the galaxies behind it.
But that's a really good thing
because we know how it does it.
And by looking at the
pattern of multiple images
and distortions, you can
reconstruct the distribution
of mass in that cluster, and
that's what the next slide is.
So these are the two coordinates
on the sky that you just saw,
so this coordinate
and that coordinate.
And the up coordinate is how
much mass at a given position.
And so these spiky
little things tell you
how good this technique is.
These are the
individual galaxies
that you saw in
that previous image.
And you might say, well,
where's the dark matter?
Well, the dark matter
isn't quite so conspicuous,
but it's this
smooth distribution
that goes on forever.
So your eye is attracted
to these little spikes,
but there's much more matter
in this smooth distribution.
So we can actually image it.
OK.
In the 1970s-- again,
these damn girl
astronomers-- Vera Rubin
really convinced people
that this was an important
problem because she
showed that without dark matter,
galaxies would fly apart.
So this is the Andromeda galaxy.
And in a galaxy, stars
orbit around the center
of the galaxy.
And so she carefully
measured the speeds
of the different
stars, stars close in,
stars farther away,
farther away, farther away.
And the name of the
name of her result
is she found flat
rotation curves.
And so what this meant was
there was a lot more to a galaxy
than that that meets
the eye, and let
me try to talk my
way through this.
So if all of the
mass of a galaxy
were associated
with the stars, it
would be a bit
puzzling that when
you get to the rare star
or gas cloud way out here,
it's moving just as fast.
Because you know, gravity falls
off like 1 over R-squared.
So what's holding this-- how
can these stars out here be
moving as fast as those stars?
And so what you can't
see with the telescope
is the enormous
halo of dark matter.
OK.
So let me talk about what
the dark matter is, and I
alluded to this earlier.
The amount of matter in
the universe, the 27%,
and the amount of atoms
in the universe, the 4.5%,
those numbers aren't equal.
And to show you how
unequal they are--
so this is not 4.5% but
it's a different measure
of the amount of atoms.
So here's the amount
of atoms on a ruler.
It's 21 plus or minus 1.
The total amount of matter
is a 130 plus or minus 5.
And so those numbers are
just wildly different.
So the dark matter
can't be atoms.
It has to be a new
form of matter.
And you know, Carl
Sagan reminded us
that we're made
out of star stuff,
and we thought that
was really cool.
But now I'm going to
tell you the universe
isn't made out of star stuff.
It's made out of
this dark matter.
So what is it?
[LAUGHTER]
So we don't know what it is.
It's hard for a theorist
to say that, you know?
But here is our best hypothesis.
In fact, this is our most
conservative hypothesis.
I'm not saying it's right,
but this is the corner
we've worked ourselves into.
That the dark matter
is made of a new kind
of particle of nature.
And the three possibilities
when I drew this slide in 1990
were a particle
called the axion,
a particle called the
neutralino, which I'll tell you
more about, and then
everybody in the room
has heard of neutrinos.
And in 1990, we thought
that the dark matter just
might be neutrinos.
We knew how many neutrinos
there were leftover from the Big
Bang, but it turns out that
their masses-- we've now
measured their masses
and they don't weigh
enough to be the dark matter.
So they're a little
cosmic spice,
but they're not the dark matter.
So let me tell you
about the neutralino.
So this is a
hypothetical particle,
which is a fancy word that means
it doesn't exist as far as we
know, but we hope it exists.
This is a particle
that, if it exists,
weighs 100, maybe 200, maybe
500 times what a proton does.
This is a particle
whose existence
has been predicted by
particle physicists who
were working on a whole
different class of problems.
Everybody's heard
of string theory?
of string theory.
OK.
Everybody's heard
of Brian Greene?
Yeah.
OK.
So if string theory is right,
for every particle we know,
there's a
super-symmetric partner.
And the neutralino is the
lightest super-symmetric
partner.
It's a particle whose existence
traces to string theory.
And so you might ask, where
are these neutralinos?
Well, the answer
that Brian would give
is, we're about
to discover them.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'll tell you why.
And then there's
another particle
that I don't have time
to tell you about.
Again, it's a
hypothetical particle
that solves a problem
in the subatomic world.
And this particle
is called the axion,
and it couldn't be more
different than the neutralino.
It weighs about a million,
million, million times less
than the neutralino, so there'd
have to be a lot of them.
What's wonderful about
these particles is,
even though we don't know
whether or not they exist,
their predicted
particles allow us
to calculate how
many of them would
be leftover from the Big Bang.
And guess what the answer is?
Enough to be that dark matter.
So this is where we are.
This is an extraordinarily
bold hypothesis.
It might not be right.
It's time to test it.
And so I like to call this
the decade of dark matter.
Let's see, do you have
a basketball team here?
[LAUGHTER]
Did you guys know that
Hubble was a basketball star,
and that he led the University
of Chicago to three NCAA titles
in a row?
[LAUGHTER]
Check that out,
that's a true fact.
[LAUGHTER]
So one way you can
verify the dark matter--
what do I mean that we have
the full court press on it?
One is that you could
produce it in an accelerator.
Now, we hoped to
produce it at Fermilab,
but Fermilab didn't
have enough energy.
And there is a new accelerator
in Geneva, Illinois--
or no, maybe it's
Geneva, Switzerland.
[LAUGHTER]
It's one of those
Geneva's, called
the Large Hadron Collider.
And if you ever visit the
Large Hadron Collider,
you go up on the wall
there and they say,
wanted, dead or alive.
The first picture is Osama bin
Laden and the second picture
is the neutralino.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
If indeed the dark matter
is made out of particles,
then we're swimming in
dark matter in this room.
So in a coffee cup, there's
about one neutralino.
And so if you built a
sensitive enough detector,
you could detect
the neutralinos.
The halo, sometimes
these neutralinos bump
into each other and annihilate,
you know, destroy each other,
and turn into particles
that we can detect,
like photons, or
electrons, or positrons.
And then it could be that the
very first generations of stars
were actually made
of neutralinos.
So we feel like in
the next 10 years,
we may finish this story of
dark matter, just in time
to start the next story.
So what about the dark energy?
So this story starts in
1998 with the discovery
that the universe is speeding
up and not slowing down.
And this was on the cover
of Science Magazine.
And this was called the
breakthrough discovery
of the year.
So let me remind you about
the expansion of the universe.
So here's the size of
the universe versus time.
And so remember that the
expansion of the universe
is just the stretching of space.
And so this we call the
cosmic scale factor.
And so as this green
curve gets bigger,
the universe is getting bigger.
This is the Big Bang.
And so one of the issues,
going back to Hubble,
is how much is the
universe slowing down?
Because gravity is
attractive, right?
And so your mother,
you all saw this.
Your mother showed you
this curve on your knee,
on her knee, or maybe your knee.
I don't know how that works.
But you first heard about
this story from your mother.
She said, the
universe is expanding.
It's slowing down so that
these curves are droopy,
so they're getting
slower and slower.
And if there's a lot of
matter in the universe,
the universe will halt expanding
and then fall back on itself.
And if there's not very
much matter in the universe,
the universe will
slow, and slow,
and then eventually
it won't slow anymore.
And then there's a Goldilocks
universe that slows, and slows,
and slows, and slows.
And at an infinite time
after the Big Bang,
it stops expanding.
And so one of the big
issues in cosmology
was to measure the
slowing of the universe.
And this is very, very hard,
but you use the Hubble diagram.
So here's the
Hubble diagram where
you plot the velocity of a
galaxy versus its distance.
And now this is the one time I
really want you to concentrate.
There is no joke coming,
so don't worry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is the Hubble diagram.
And if we measured velocities
and distances of galaxies
today, due to the fact that
the expansion of the universe
is just space expanding,
we'd get a straight line.
But we cannot
measure those today.
We cannot measure
the velocities today,
because when we look through a
telescope and we look at a very
distant object, we're
looking back in time.
And so when we look at
the most distant objects,
we're not measuring
the velocity today.
We're measuring the
velocity way back when.
And if the universe is slowing
down, the number we measure
should actually be
above the straight line.
And so going back to
Hubble, astronomers
have been trying to put
galaxies on this diagram,
on the Hubble diagram, ones
that are way far away, to see
the bending of the curve.
And if the universe is slowing
down, it would curve upward.
And the amount it curves upward,
like if it curved like that,
it's really slowing down
if just curves a little.
So that was the goal.
Now, in order to do this, you
need to accurately measure
distances.
And to accurately measure
distances in astronomy,
you need an object whose
brightness you know,
and then you measure its
apparent brightness here.
And if it's very faint,
it's very far away.
And so we call these
standard candles.
And the best standard
candle that we know of,
the standard candle that
really makes this work,
is called a Type 1a Supernova.
And it's basically
a star about 40%
more massive than our
sun that just blows up.
So it's a 1.4 solar
mass thermonuclear bomb.
And so you can see them
across the universe.
So here's a very distant galaxy,
and here's a Type 1a Supernova.
All of these are
distant galaxies,
and you can see the supernova.
And I just want
to put in a pitch
here because the person
who really pointed out
that these were good standard
candles and figured out
how they work is
Dave Arnett, who's
a professor here at the
University of Arizona,
and wrote the book
on supernovae.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, actually, he did
this work while he was
at the University of Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So these objects, by
finding these supernovae,
you can put data points on this
diagram, on the Hubble diagram.
And here's what
was found in 1998.
So all the points lay
below the straight line.
And if you followed the argument
about why this bends upward
if the universe is
slowing down, then you
would realize this means
the universe is speeding up.
And a lot of measurements and
other data have been taken,
and the universe
really is speeding up.
And so how the heck
can that be possible?
And the reason is, is that
general relativity-- GR
stands for general
relativity-- allows
for gravity to be repulsive.
Now, I've got to
just explain this.
I don't mean the
study of gravity
being repulsive and hard.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean that gravity
can be repulsive.
And so I'll just make a small,
little technical statement.
One of the things
that you learned
in Newton's theory of gravity
is that the strength of gravity
that an object puts
off-- ugh, that
was a terrible construction--
that the strength of gravity
or the gravitational
force of an object
depends only on its mass.
In Einstein's theory, it also
depends upon its composition
through the pressure.
And so while we don't think
mass or energy can be negative,
pressure can be
something that's elastic.
If you have a hot gas,
that's positive pressure.
If you have a rubber sheet,
that's negative pressure.
And so P can be negative.
And if you have something
that's very, very elastic,
this combination
can be negative,
and the gravity that produces
instead of being attractive
is repulsive.
Are you with me?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
I think you are.
And so, stuff that has repulsive
gravity is called dark energy.
So cosmic acceleration is
caused by the repulsive gravity
of dark energy.
Are there any questions?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Let me tell you a little
bit more about this stuff.
I should start at the bottom.
This stuff is weird,
it's mysterious,
and it's extremely exciting.
And if you're confused when
I'm done discussing it,
you have caught up
with the rest of us.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So it's not made
out of particles.
It's highly elastic.
It's gravity is repulsive,
and it is everywhere.
So this is really weird stuff.
We don't understand it.
So here is our best explanation
for the dark energy.
And as you'll see, it's
not a very good one.
So this is the Zen
part of the talk.
So this involves
asking, what is nothing?
[LAUGHTER]
So according to
quantum mechanics,
nothing is something.
Actually, that sounds
like American economy.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway, according
to quantum mechanics,
the vacuum is filled with
particles living on borrowed
time and borrowed energy.
And let me just show you.
Time is running up.
An electron and
its anti-particle
can pump out of the
vacuum for a little while
and then disappear.
And so we know the
vacuum is seething.
It's a sea of virtual particles.
And in fact, Willis
Lamb, who I believe
spent part of his career here,
but he did the experiments
at Chicago.
[LAUGHTER]
Actually, he did them
at Columbia University.
Measured the effects of
these virtual particles.
So they really are there.
And this part I'm just going
to ask you to accept on faith.
Otherwise, I'm going to put a
whole bunch of equations up.
That if this vacuum energy--
if these virtual particles have
energy, we call it vacuum
energy-- if they have energy,
their pressure is equal to
minus their energy density.
That is, they're
extraordinarily elastic.
So that this combination of
row plus 3P is minus 2 row.
Very, very elastic.
OK.
So how much does nothing weigh?
And this is where a theorist
just starts to babble.
[LAUGHTER]
Because the truth is, we don't
know how much nothing weighs.
In fact, to be really
honest, when we actually
try to add up how much all of
these virtual particles weigh,
we get infinity, which
is a little too big.
When we use some
tricks that we're not
sure that are correct, then we
get almost the right answer.
We find out that the
repulsive gravity of nothing
is very close to
being the right amount
to explain the
accelerating universe.
It's off by about 10 to the 55.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's kind of the same
size problem as our deficit.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So actually, this is
the part where I just
want to wax poetic and get
really excited, because this
is what science is all about.
So we started with one puzzle.
Why is the universe speeding up?
And now we have two puzzles.
So the second puzzle-- oops--
the second puzzle is, why
does nothing weigh so little?
And by the way, what
about that first puzzle?
So this is what we live
for in science, is puzzles.
And theorists really
like hard puzzles
because solving
hard puzzles often
requires a crazy new idea.
Now, I know you can
all find my email,
and so I just want you
to carefully read this.
"Not every crazy idea is a
solution to a profound puzzle."
[LAUGHTER]
Most of them are just crazy.
So OK.
So let's see, what
did I have to say?
Oh, here's my crazy idea.
So not only did I invent
the term dark energy,
but you've got to
play both sides.
You know, you have to hedge.
It's a hedge fund.
So I also wrote a paper saying,
there is no dark energy.
It's just a new
aspect of gravity.
Einstein was wrong.
And when the universe
gets really, really empty,
it accelerates.
And our universe has gotten
really, really empty.
So it's expanded
a long, long time.
And so its density has
decreased by about 100 orders
of magnitude.
Now, actually, I don't think
this idea works, but it might.
Oh, here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
So one thing that's
really important
is towards the end of a talk,
to wake people up, you have
to put some boy-girl sex in.
[LAUGHTER]
And does anyone-- everybody
knows who this good looking guy
is, right?
Burt Lancaster.
What about her?
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, OK.
Good.
OK.
So let's--
[LAUGHTER]
Where did that
picture come from?
OK.
I don't know where
that picture came from.
Oh, back to this picture.
So this is what your mother told
you when you were a little baby
and you were on her knee
and she was telling you
about the Big Bang.
[LAUGHTER]
And she told you about
the universe slowing down.
And a universe that had
the Goldilocks density
and was flat, you
know, was slowing down.
And that's our universe.
But things are speeding up.
So now we have the
biggest dilemma of all.
Was your mother wrong?
[LAUGHTER]
And the answer is, no.
Because as you were
falling asleep, she said,
this is the simplest
version of the story.
This is a story where
there's no dark energy.
But if there's dark energy,
an uncurved universe
can actually be speeding up.
And all I wanted to say
here is, until we understand
what the dark energy
is, we don't know
the destiny of our universe.
We don't know if it's
going to be a big crunch
or expansion forever.
OK.
So I wander around the halls
at the University of Chicago
saying, dark energy may be the
most profound problem in all
of science, and it's really
good that other great minds
agree with me.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So I bet you all--
you know, that's
the thing about people today.
They don't read the whole book.
So the whole interview,
I bet none of you
watched the whole interview.
And the biggest question was,
Katie Couric asked Sarah Palin,
what about dark energy?
And she said, you betcha, Katie.
I believe in dark energy.
We can see it from Alaska.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, of course, that's
the Northern Lights,
but she spelled it right.
[LAUGHTER]
And now I'm going to
show you something
that not so many
people have seen.
This is going to be her
bumper sticker in 2012.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
I'm getting the
sign from the dean
that I'm not getting
paid by the hour,
so I've to wind this
up here pretty soon.
So when are we going
to solve this puzzle?
I don't know, and that's what
makes this puzzle so exciting.
And I hope there's some
young people in the audience
because I have a
feeling that we're not
going to solve this puzzle.
It's going to be
the next generation.
Some kid in the audience here
is going to figure this one out
before I do.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you have some good ideas,
come up afterwards and see me.
[APPLAUSE]
And we can write
a paper together.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
But there is going to be some
more information about how fast
the universe is speeding up.
We hope to build a telescope
in the US called WFIRST.
And those damn Europeans,
everything we do,
they try to copy.
And we are building, for sure,
the Large Synoptic Survey
Telescope, which will
be Roger Angel mirrors,
but it won't be in Arizona.
But that's not my fault.
OK.
Right, let me go on and
talk about inflation
and then finish up
with the multiverse.
So there was an idea
in the 1980s that
has been probably the
most influential idea
since the idea of the Big Bang,
and it's called inflation.
And what it really is is
this brown sentence here.
"A a very short period
of rapid expansion
driven by vacuum energy."
And in the 1980s, we were
afraid to call this accelerated
expansion because the idea
was so crazy that if we added
accelerated expansion,
which is what it really is,
nobody would have
listened to us.
So how rapid?
In 10 to the -32
seconds-- for those of you
who don't know what that
is, we just call it a jiffy.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I don't know powers
of 10 either.
So in a jiffy, the universe
expanded by a larger factor
than it did in the
next 15 billion years.
And our observable universe
began from an incredibly tiny
piece of the original universe.
And that explains
why it's so smooth,
and also explains where
the lumps come from.
So let me just run
you through that idea.
So here is the
universe, very early on.
One of the big puzzles is why
is our universe so smooth?
Why did the microwave
background look so smooth?
So a tiny, little
bit of the universe
blows up due to
this vacuum energy.
And for those of you who
know a little more physics,
you can look at this
picture up there.
[LAUGHTER]
Not that I understand
that picture up there,
but so this tiny, little
bit of the universe
blows up, creating a big,
smooth region of the universe.
And because it was
so tiny, it was flat.
So creating a big, smooth
uncurved universe--
oh, that's what we have--
that all that we see today
can fit in.
And this is the
most amazing thing,
and this is why
Stephen Hawking called
the discovery by COBE the
greatest discovery of all time,
is that this explains where the
seeds for structure come from.
So everyone knows that
at the subatomic world,
things are bouncing around.
Things can't be smooth.
We call them fluctuations.
And so in the subatomic world,
you have these fluctuations.
And so you might say, oh, well,
that would be really good.
So higher density here,
lower density there.
But the size of these is less
than the size of an atom.
So how could you make a galaxy?
This tremendous
expansion of the universe
stretches the fluctuations.
Well, let me go back here.
Just like it blows up this
piece and makes it really big,
it stretches the size
of these fluctuations.
So that instead of being
less than the size of an atom
across, they're millions
of light years across.
And so you get more matter
here and less matter there.
And so that makes the
lumpiness in the universe.
And if that's correct, this--
what you see on the microwave
sky-- is quantum noise.
And the biggest thing-- it
got blown up by inflation.
And the biggest things
in the universe,
galaxies, clusters of galaxies,
are made from subatomic quantum
fluctuations.
Now, usually at this
point in the talk,
I look for the men in white
coats to be pulling me off.
So that's an amazing idea.
Since that didn't
happen, I'll show
you one more slide about this.
So this means when you
look at the microwave
sky-- this is from
WMAP-- you are looking
at the world's largest IMAX.
So you are looking
at the quantum
world projected across the sky.
And what you see across 10
or 20 degrees of the sky
started out, at a
length scale, smaller
than a billionth of
the size of a proton.
So that's amazing.
And let's see, I don't
really have much time
to talk about this.
But this kind of lumpiness
plus the dark matter
is called cold dark
matter scenario.
And this gives us a story
of how galaxies and clusters
of galaxies were formed that we
can test with these telescopes
that we build with
Roger Angel mirrors.
And right now, so far,
the status of this theory
is really good.
When I showed you those points
from the microwave background,
there was a curve through them.
It wasn't a curve
that I asked my son
to draw to fit all the points.
That's actually what
theory predicted.
OK.
Now I'm going to
give you the part,
this is the hardest
part of the talk.
This is the one that's really
going to keep you up at night.
So if you're not a good
sleeper, close your eyes
and put your hands
over your ears.
So inflation says that what we
used to think of as the capital
B, capital B Big Bang was
kind of little b little b,
our Big Bang.
It was the start
of our universe.
Because according to
inflation, if it happened once,
it happened many times.
Now, you know mathematicians
and scientists,
when they say many times, what
they really mean is infinity.
But if they said infinity, it
would make you feel nervous.
And so this leads to the idea,
the inflationary multiverse.
And here is another
Monet painting,
and this has to do with--
here's the river of time.
And in some ways,
there was no beginning.
There were an infinite
number of beginnings.
And so each one of
these inflation events
creates a universe,
and these universes
are completely disconnected.
They can't talk to one another.
And so we call this
idea the multiverse.
And they might-- if you marry
this with string theory--
why you would do
that, I don't know--
but if you marry this
with string theory,
then these different regions,
these different pieces
of the universe, might
be very different.
Here's our beautiful universe.
Others might be empty or
have lower dimensions.
And this idea is either
the most important idea
since Copernicus or it's the
biggest headache of all time.
Why is it a headache?
Because these different
pieces of the multiverse
can't communicate.
And if they can't communicate,
how can we test it?
And if we can't test it,
how can it be science?
And so that's why
this is a headache,
because it's a really important
idea that might even be true.
But we can't test it,
and so it's not science.
And I just want to go back.
What we can test is whether or
not our piece of the universe
happened from inflation,
and we are doing that.
So what do you do when
you get a cosmic headache?
Well, you drink a bottle
of multiverse beer.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So let me just wrap up here.
So I talked about our
understanding of the universe,
and we're very excited about it.
We know a lot
about the universe,
but it's predicated on
dark matter, dark energy,
and inflation.
And these are mysteries.
And they all imply
physics or laws of nature
that we have yet to discover.
Let me just explain that with
a very complicated diagram.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm just going to be quiet
for a minute or two while you
read this.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So what this is is, this
is an amazing summary
of what we know about the
world of the subatomic.
So here you see the word quarks,
and leptons, and everything
we know about it.
And if you study
this very carefully,
you will not find in it
dark matter, dark energy,
or inflation.
So this is a
tremendous achievement,
but it doesn't include
dark matter, dark energy,
and inflation.
And so that means that our
list of the laws of physics
and the fundamental pieces of
the universe is incomplete.
And so this is the
most exciting thing
that there are deep connections
between the universe,
the biggest thing
that we can imagine,
and the elementary particles,
the smallest things.
That's the purpose
of this picture.
Here is the sky and these
are a bubble chambers
of elementary particles.
So dark matter, when we
figure out what it is,
it's a new particle
in nature and it
might tell us how the forces
of nature are unified.
Dark energy, is it the
energy of nothing or-- oops.
Yeah, you really do
have bad equipment here.
[LAUGHTER]
Or is signaling that something's
wrong with general relativity?
And so on.
So we have these
deep connections.
Figuring out dark
matter is not only
going to help us
understand the cosmos,
it's probably going to help us
understand the subatomic world
and how the forces are unified.
And we're going to get
clues from a whole bunch
of experiments, accelerators,
specialize-- this is a detector
to detect dark matter.
And you see some
more telescopes here.
And this is an
extraordinarily exciting time.
And let me use some pictures
that my daughter helped me
draw when she was very young.
So we know much
about the universe.
So I told you about inflation.
I mentioned the word
string, so I'm allowed
to put string cosmology here.
The Hot Big Bang,
massive neutrinos.
We have all of this.
We know a lot, but
we understand less.
And so the goal is to
put it all together.
And this is big
stakes, very exciting.
Because if we think we can put
the picture of the universe
together, we're
also going to learn
about the fundamental rules
that govern the universe.
And so I asked my daughter,
can you help me here?
What do we got?
And she said, daddy,
you have an elephant.
[LAUGHTER]
And so the metaphor
here, the metaphor
here is the blind
man and the elephant.
So we're the blind cosmologists
feeling the universe.
We feel these different
pieces, but we haven't
seen the big picture yet.
And so that's the challenge
for the next generation.
So it's very, very exciting, and
I thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]